I've spent the last decade crafting
beautiful architectural homes all over
Western Australia and there is an
essential step that is often overlooked
by Architects and designers which
generally leaves them staring at blank
space clueless of where to begin their
design process the architecture turn
brief is by far the most important piece
in a great architectural design store
pay with close attention a riddle that
will gift one lucky viewer my brief
completely for free how when why well
you're about to find out let's go let's
dive in to this architectural return
brief that I'm hoping you guys will be
able to use in your practice to be able
to produce better architecture by using
this as a guide instead of staring at
Blake white spaces hoping for
inspiration so first of all we're going
to walk our way through the existing
temp template and then also show you a
fully completed version as well starting
off we have our cover page which you can
manipulate and introduce your very own
at the moment it's just styled to my
personal branding scrolling through we
of course have our introductory page and
our Index this is generally not too much
information that you need to really
worry about but it's nice documentation
to have and showcase the clients
throughout the video we'll be going
through each one of these sections the
index and contents with based covered
already but the details through to the
design language is really what's going
to set your projects apart as you
progress through the designs now I will
mention this is crafted specifically for
residential projects you can use it on
commercials but obviously there's going
to be so much that isn't applicable or
so much missing so if you're doing
residential projects especially high-end
residential architecture this is a
perfect example of how you should
implement it into your own workflows
first of all we of course start with the
who the who is is the most important and
it talks about our actual clients it
talks about their personal details so
this is the information that we
generally need to know about them
throughout the entire project I find it
is best to ask these clients all the
questions up front rather than
continuously pestering them throughout
the project for more and more
information so if you can manage to get
out all of the information such as their
company name the business identification
numbers all of the addresses all of the
billing details it's going to SA them a
ton of time and you a ton of headaches
chasing up this information later down
the track of course at the bottom we
have our coffee and our tea preferences
as well as food allergies generally once
you get to the high level of
architecture it's very nice to offer
your clients tea coffee some food some
snacks throughout your meeting
especially if those meetings are going
to go for a while product selection
meetings material selections meetings
these can take four five six even eight
hours sometimes to really go through
everything in nitty-gritty detail and
you want to provide the clients with the
best experience possible if you ask them
the questions at the start by the time
you get to that stage of the project
it'll appear as if you've remembered
some of the finest details about this
people which really shows personality
and Care Moving on next after our cents
is of course the what the project what
are we doing what are we designing what
are we spending our money on and of
course we need to know same sort of
details these intricate details allow
you to have a cheap cheat for your
project as you start designing knowing
where the property is the land size the
type the photos what the client actually
wants how they want it constructed how
you prefer it to be constructed is all
critical information if you're going to
design a concrete home fully cast in
situe on site it's going to be very
different to how you design a brick Co
house or even a Timber framed home so
some of these critical details will get
your mind working very very early on
which is incredible when you're stuck
for inspiration and once you start
having more and more clients come
through then you might start offering
additional services are you just doing
the architectural home package yes we
are are you doing the landscape design
yes we are and you can go through all of
these individually tick them untick them
and create them exactly as you need to
be so that way you can reference this
one document again and save yourself a
ton of time we get quite detailed and
quite intricate in our Pro Pro
requirements because this forms the
architectural return brief it is the
basis of what needs to be done for the
project if the brief changes the budget
changes the fees change these project
details continue through every single
room the living room the family room in
some cases you might have a gym an
office elevators laundry shoots and
extra bits and pieces they may want
underfloor heating or INF Flor hydronic
heating all these things need to be
considered very very early on to make
them feasible at the end of a project
and of course you don't stop with the
indoors you have to go to the outdoors
as well we need to talk about the
entertaining areas their requirements in
their drawing yards their visitors Bays
their car parking requirements their
vehicle sizes if they have large
vehicles and they can't turn into their
own property that's going to be a
nightmare so you want to understand
exactly what vehicles are going in from
day one now this document obviously is
pages and pages long just on the project
details because this is fundamentally
and crucially important so that's why
you need to spend bulk of your time on
this section right here moving on to our
why the why is what sets Architects
apart from others we are doing things
with purpose with care and with intent
if you aren't doing them with care and
intent you're just designing for the
sake of Designing and you may as well
throw it out to AI at the moment we want
to ask some serious personal questions
this is generally interpreted relatively
quickly when you meet somebody face to
face but if you can prefill this these
questionnaires in it's going to serve
you well in the long term for instance
is it a personal project or is it an
investment property these two designs
are completely different investment
properties is all about budget breaking
and making sure they make a profit
personal projects it almost doesn't
matter if it's personal they're happy to
spend the money on key items and they
really want to see this thing be perfect
for them so some of these questions may
seem irrelevant but they play huge pival
roles in the architectural design the
way we actually produce our work and how
we go around this process some things we
don't often ask our clients is social
media as well at the bottom of this
personal question here I have do you
have a social media policy do you
require discretion sometimes if you're
working with high-profile clients they
don't like to be known they don't like
to be talked about and they especially
don't like their project shared on
social media even though this may make
or break your career their privacy is
more important than anything so you have
to respect their privacy and you have to
ask these questions what I find is often
incredibly powerful and Incredibly
important exercise at the very start
he's asking the client to produce a
negotiable and a non-negotiable list if
the budget is constrained or if the
project is actually constrained and you
don't have enough space a negotiable and
non-negotiable list helps you predefine
exactly what you can rip out without the
client's request or what you need to
incorporate into that design if it's
non-negotiable that they need a
fivestory home then you have to design
it if it's feasible but it could be a
negotiable Factor they may only want a
two-story home but if it all fits on one
story fantastic They Don't Really Care
these items are really important to
understand early on so ask your clients
to take this page home go through it in
time detail and really put some care and
effort into it because what they think
and what you might think is negotiable
and non-negotiable could be polls apart
and because there is so much that could
be negotiable and non-negotiable we
break this down by level as well talking
about each individual area of the actual
plan so is there something that's
negotiable in the basement is it not do
you have to have your car park there do
you not all of these questions can be
answered relatively quickly but need to
be asked next we move on to a key
component that is often a bit
uncomfortable to talk about with some
people how much are you willing to spend
on this project and what portion of that
fund are you expecting to spend on what
area often people come in and they'll
say I'm ready to spend $1 million on
this house but what they don't
understand is that there's a lot more to
a house than just the $1 million budget
so that's why we've broken down the
turnkey budgets into separate categories
and stages if you want to spend a
million dollars fantastic but is that
million dollars dedicated to the whole
project including interior selections
landscape design lighting design your
furniture and everything or is that
literally just for the turnkey product
that is the house if you can identify
and segregate each of these items and
say I want to spend a million on the
house I want to spend 100,000 on
Interiors I want to spend
$30,000 or $300,000 on Landscaping then
you can know how far you can push each
area of the component and each area of
the design now this is where we stop
staring at blank spaces and we start
staring at actual architectural
inspiration here I've broken down every
single space commonly found in
architectural residential projects and
I've provided five key images with a
description that you can add or your
client can add so that you know exactly
what elements you're pulling from often
you get a Pinterest board which is
fantastic there's a million images but
they might like just that one section of
one image and not the whole image at all
you could be looking at that image going
Ah that's I see their Vision but you've
got it completely wrong whereas here you
have five key images for each area and
it's outlined specifically what is good
and what is bad about each of those
sections so if we scroll through you'll
see we have areas for landscaping entry
statements kitchens living and so on I
can keep scrolling there's many many
many many pages of this which really
takes a bit of time but again this is
what sets architecture apart having a
clear concise brief is going to help you
design the perfect home every single
time rather than guessing from the GetGo
once you've completed all of those pages
of course you have completed your
architectural return brief and you can
sign off on this and start designing now
this all looks well and good as a blank
document but what does it look like
completed let's close this package here
and move on to the completed package
this is hours of work it is not a very
simple task to do but it is a Critic
step and I cannot emphasize that anymore
than I am already you need to take the
time and care to fill this out properly
so let's scroll through and examine what
this looks like completed I've obviously
blanked out areas here for privacy so
let's scroll through this and you'll see
what actually this looks like so of
course we have all of our clients
address details information personal
details such as their mobile phone
numbers their email addresses exactly
where they live what kind of coffees
they like what kind of coffees they
don't like any allergies do their
children have allergies what are their
children's names and so forth in this
project we're looking to design it on a
1500 met Block it's r25 in Australian
residential zoning is an ocean front
property which immediately to me means
we have to design for Coastal conditions
I know the block is sloping the photos
of the block are linked obviously
removed and ideally they want a
two-story home but it could be three
they'd like it to be timber frame
construction with concrete suspended
floors and a Timber structured roof so
we've got some perfect starting notes of
where we can actually begin our design
we also have a critical bit of
information from the client saying that
a neighbor may cause some problems due
to previous history and that the water
table is very low and that we should not
even Explore a basement if we didn't
have this inside knowledge onto the
property from the client there's no way
in hell we would have known that without
spending some money and doing some
testing and in this instance we're
providing a full service package but
we're not documenting the existing home
because it's a blank slate everything
that the client once in each individual
room has been itemized and discussed
early on now we've talked about the
sizing of their master bedroom the
minimum requirements we've talked about
the walk-in robe requirements we've
talked about how many people might be
coming and visiting them and if there's
a chef on board as well all of these
items make a massive massive difference
in how we design now this takes time and
it doesn't always work with every client
sometimes clients just want you to start
but other times when you can actually
spend the time understand learn people
on a personal level this will help you
become a better architect and design
better for them of course we've gone
through that on every single room we've
done it in great detail even to the
externals where we talk about the fire
pits the type of lawn if it's fake or if
it's natural we talk about
security systems and rainwater
collections everything so we know where
to start now the why of course makes the
biggest difference have they worked with
an architect before yes they know
exactly the process so we don't need to
babysit them throughout the whole thing
but this isn't just the first home this
is their last home that means they're
willing to spend whatever they need to
to be able to live in the perfect time
that they want if that means going
slightly over budget they've advised
they're happy to do that but it also
means we still have a budget to talk
about they're retiring which also means
we need to think about disability
compliant Aging in place potentially
some lifts some elevators and some hand
rails on our stairs we need to really
think about how these clients will live
in the space not just the space itself
and this information here provides us
with invaluable information moving on
they've said that the negotiable list is
that the pool can be 20 M originally if
we scroll back up to the top they've
asked for a 25 M lap pull and no Spar so
obviously a 20 M pull is still
sufficient but they' much rather a 25 P
meter pull if it doesn't fit now that is
something that's critical and you
automatically know that you can pull it
back if you need to again they've broken
the negotiables up into individual areas
and some spaces there's just not
unnegotiable on the second floor they
don't care what's there but on the first
floor they really want want the sleeping
areas here and the laundry so ideally we
try to stick to that otherwise we have a
bit more free Reigns and understanding
into our client's mind than before when
we're just trying to read mines now we
get on to the igr and of course it is
broken up into exactly how they plan on
spending their money $3 million for the
house half a million do for their
interior collections half a million on
the Landscaping 250,000 on architectural
lighting design and high-end finishes as
well as what I'm expecting should have
been
$300,000 on furniture art and wall
coverings obviously a zero Miss there
now we've gone through this and spent a
serious amount of time looking at the
exterior what they like so for instance
they love the cascading plants in this
photo if you looked at this photo
previously and just looked at it you
might have thought they love the white
render because they also love the white
and black combo here but you may have
completely misunderstood the cascading
plants they talk about lighting features
the concrete and the stone so we know
we're working with those elements first
off to start our architectural language
the Landscaping is very natural very
beautiful dark greens illuminated
carefully crafted spaces which is again
very critical and important so we have a
good idea of what this space should look
like and could look like of course we
move on to our entry statements we get
some Grand ideas of what it may look
like their kitchen their Stone
selections the general theme of how this
house is coming together they like the
lights in this first one behind but they
also like the stone in the second one
and they're like the wooden third one
they've provided a ton of living room
examples which are absolutely beautiful
some dining spaces double boids lights
concrete renders Master selections how
they want all of this to tie in now
obviously this is a well-crafted return
brief we have inspiration into their
Master on Suite we have ins spiration
into the soul of this architectural home
and as we continue through all of this
provides more and more inspiration for
us again we look at these images as a
starting point we understand where we're
going what direction we're heading in
which is significantly better than
looking at a blank page now there's no
theater room in this one there's no
inspiration so it was left completely
blank whereas the garage is pretty
high-end it is incredibly well crafted
at the start of this video I provided a
very sneaky little riddle I said pay
with close attention if you have been
paying close attention throughout this
video and you want this brief completely
for free including the architectural
example with all of this that I've
showcased on today's video you can go to
my website it's linked down below and
you can use the coupon code close
attention all capitals to download this
free now only the first lucky viewer to
figure this out watch this video to the
end we'll figure it out and hopefully
you'll be able to use this in your own
practice anyway that's all from me team
my name's David tomich I hope you
enjoyed the video if you did make sure
you smash the Subscribe button down
below leave any comments and I'll
hopefully answer them as soon as I can
like always I'll see you next week